thousands of airline passengers are
stuck in Atlanta this morning after a
massive power outage shut down the
world's busiest airport an electrical
fire knocked out power for nearly 11
hours yesterday at hartsfield-jackson
Atlanta International Airport power was
restored just before midnight
more than 1,100 flights were canceled
yesterday and more than 400 flights are
already canceled today about 30,000
passengers were stranded some say they
were stuck on the tarmac for at least
seven hours with no food or water as if
flying wasn't stressful enough officials
are still evaluating the cause Kris Van
Cleave is at hartsfield-jackson in
Atlanta with the major disruption at the
key hub Chris good morning well good
morning and many of those 30,000
travelers are going to be trying to get
out of here today let me show you what
the airport looks like as we take a view
here this really came at an awful time
the airlines look at Sunday as the start
of the Christmas travel rush and this is
an airport that's busy on a good day 275
thousand passengers on average 2,500
planes coming and going so today really
becomes about recovery cheers of joy
late Sunday night at Atlanta's
hartsfield-jackson airport when the
lights finally came back on well it's
great when the lights came on blackout
in Atlanta but for much of the day this
is what the inside of the nation's
busiest airport looked like thousands of
passengers stranded inside as the
airport ground to a standstill we were
literally carrying old people down the
escalators and up escalators and
carrying wheelchairs and my heart was
like racing because I'm scared for these
people's lives
let's move walked down that the
escalator which was a nightmare then we
have to go through the tunnels or pitch
black it's scary that was a nightmare
hundreds more travelers were stuck
inside airplanes waiting for a gate we
sat on the tarmac for six hours
five month-old with me now we're trying
to get to Fort Myers but all the flights
have been canceled power Georgia
Electric believes switch gear failed
sparking an underground fire that took
out backup systems and substations
powering the airport Atlanta mayor Kasim
Reed but I want to be very clear we do
have a redundant system but it was
impacted by the intensity of the fire
with well over 1,000 flights canceled
the power outage hit Delta the hardest
Atlanta is its main hub but continued
issues Monday in Atlanta could mean
problems at airports across the country
so as a result you have this terrible
mess with airplanes not where they
should be crews not where they should be
and passengers not where they should be
and that's part of why Delta canceled
more than 300 flights mainly this
morning as they try to restart normal
operations by midday of course the big
question now is how does a fire in your
primary system take out your redundant
system that's going to be a question
Flyers are gonna want an answer to Norah
all right Chris thank you great to have
you there in Atlanta